il me passe bonjour Stéphanie il faut
dire que cette visite au Pays-Bas de
volodimeki c'est un peu une visite
surprise il a notamment je le disais
rencontrer les magistrats de la Cour
pénale internationale
oui effectivement il était là ce matin
il est resté il a il a rencontré les
magistrats le président de la Cour
pénale internationale le chèque puis
autre Offman skin il n'a pas rencontré
le procureur qui est actuellement en
déplacement vous savez se procureur qui
a adressé un mandat d'arrêt contre
Vladimir Poutine notamment un mandat
d'arrêt pour crime de guerre pour la
déportation d'enfance Ukrainiens vers la
Russie ce mandat d'arrêt a été délivré à
la mi-mars voilà alors ce mandat a pu
être délivré parce que l'Ukraine a
accepté la compétence de la Cour pénale
internationale mais reste quand même une
question qui fâche c'est que l'Ukraine
n'a pas ratifié le traité de cette cour
il faut savoir que il suffirait au
président zellenski de prendre un décret
puisque toute la procédure a été a été
faite à Kiev mais que pour l'instant et
bien l'Ukraine ne souhaite pas ratifier
le traité de la Cour pénale
internationale et comme dans d'autres
pays et ce sont essentiellement les
militaires qui s'y opposent voilà parce
que ça impliquerait un certain nombre
d'obligations vis-à-vis de cette cour
cette qui je vous le rappelle est
compétente parce que Kiev lui a demandé
d'enquêter sur les crimes commis sur son
territoire
Stéphanie de son côté le volody marski
lui là il a renouvelé une nouvelle fois
une demande qu'il fait depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant c'est la création d'un
tribunal spécial pour juger des crimes
de guerre russes commis en Ukraine
alors plus précisément du crime
d'agression en fait la Cour pénale
internationale derrière moi peut juger
les crimes contre l'humanité et les
crimes de guerre en revanche elle n'a
pas compétence pour pouvoir juger le
crime d'agression et l'Ukraine qui est
enfin estime que c'est le crime des
crimes et que sans juger ce crime là et
bien on laissait on laisserait la porte
ouverte à d'autres crimes dans d'autres
pays à d'autres endroits dans le futur
alors voilà un peu le plaidoyer des
Ukrainiens ça fait plusieurs mois ça
fait depuis même un an depuis le drame
de boucha que les Ukrainiens plaident
pour avoir un tribunal spécial pour
l'agression et là vous l'avez entendu
monsieur volody mirzelanski a expliqué
qu'il ne souhaite pas un demi tribunal
un tribunal hybride ce qui est
actuellement ce que peuvent proposer
notamment les occidentaux notamment les
alliés de l'Ukraine en fait il faut
savoir que la France le Royaume-Uni les
États-Unis s'opposent à la création d'un
tel tribunal Ukraine que ça puisse créer
un précédent ils craignent que ça puisse
limiter la marge à Genève le droit en
quelque sorte de faire la guerre alors
voilà voilà pourquoi il y a eu ce
discours aujourd'hui de volodime
zellenski qui était assez véhément et
qui a dit qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres
solutions qu'un tribunal plein et entier
un tribunal Adobe pour juger du crime
d'agression
merci beaucoup Stéphanie pour toutes ces